we're going to begin this hour by
showing you how the american dream came
true for thousands of immigrants all at
once the people you're about to see
became u.s citizens at la's dodgers
stadium now that's not typical for this
venue for this kind of thing but it sure
fits like the major leaguers who play at
this iconic park many of those being
sworn in yesterday have worked for years
to fulfill their dreams our jonathan
bigliotti met one of those new americans
her name is mona lindo she's 89 years
old and she's been here in this country
for 42 years
you don't have to be a fan of baseball
to be moved by the emerald field of
america's national pastime
i don't really know a lot about baseball
but i guess the dodgers is my team now
for 2 100 people the hallowed ground of
dodger stadium was turned into a fitting
stage welcoming them as new citizens
i have to wait to get all the right visa
and forms to come through
sorry it's been a long time coming
yeah
from europe latin america and the
caribbean asia and africa young and old
they pledged their allegiance on this
field of their dreams in the heart of
l.a please raise your right hand among
them the oldest new american in los
angeles today 89 year old mona lindo i'm
very excited
sunday too
who we met last week ahead of her big
day i'm very very proud of my humble
beginning but i really love america
originally from jamaica she brought her
young family to la in the 80s she says
she never felt the need to become a u.s
citizen at first but having eight
children and 41 grand and
great-grandkids most of whom are now
american citizens
change things how long have you lived in
the u.s for 42 years 42 years
why did you wait until now
i wanted to retire in jamaica
but it became
all my family um decided to become a
citizen
so i make the decision to
get my
citizenship
including her daughter pam she realizes
what's going on you know politically and
she wants to be a part of that process
also i hereby declare on oath i
am very inspired she realized the
importance of it
and stuck through it
seeing newly minted americans never gets
old says united states citizenship and
immigration services director er mendoza
jadoo it is extremely special it has
been several years since we've been able
to do a big special events like like
this one and naturalize over 2 000
people from 120 countries
congratulations
if mona lindo has a message for any
other holdouts is that when it comes to
becoming an american
it's better late
than never what's your message to people
watching this now who may think
i'm too old to try something new what do
you say to those people
well it's never too late i
most think about living than dying so i
continue with my life wherever it takes
me
for cbs morning's jonathan vigliotti los
angeles really moving so incredible it's
beautiful it is congratulations mona
lindo and we we take so much for granted
in this country and see what it means to
people to come here and become a state
and it's very fitting actually that's on
a baseball field at dodger stadium
because it's not only america's pastime
but a quarter of the players more than
in fact in the big leagues are
foreign-born themselves so right
it's representative of the country and
the game it's beautiful in the
quote-unquote american dream exactly all
of us seek that's for sure